How to decrease a tumor or a growth?
Bergamit or Chaga are mentioned in an article about tumors.
Do I test out for either or are there other ways to decrease the size?
So in general, when you're treating, when we're testing for what is going to, so what
I do, you're takes while I'm testing to understand, I'm locking into cancer and I'm going from
there.
But I'm testing really for other things.
People will often ask, did you test for food sensitive?
No, we're only testing for the cancer issues.
In cheek swan testing, it's not the best way to test for food sensitive.
Did you test for other things for X, Y and Z issue that I have?
No, that's not what I'm doing.
I'm testing for the cancer and what's going to be best for the cancer.
So if we're talking about how to best way to decrease a tumor, you're talking about it's
a cancerous related tumor, then we are doing everything that we can do as far as from an
nutritional standpoint.
I wouldn't necessarily add Bergamit or Chaga or anything else that you might read about.
Unless you really, you know, you read, read about something and you're afraid about it.
You really, really, really feel strongly that God is telling you to do something that by
all means, override anything I'm telling you to do and make that decision.
We are doing the things that we want to do to decrease the size.